[Music]
heather's in los angeles hi heather
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call i have
to say this is an honor i've listened to
you since i was a teenager wow thank you
how can we help you for me
my husband and i are expecting and also
looking to move out of state
here uh in the next
six months or so when does the baby do
november the beginning of november and
you want to move right as the babies do
i know we're crazy we're looking to move
maybe around september
to arizona so hoping to miss
the really hot part but move and stuff
before the baby comes and you're going
to move in the third trimester
this is your first child isn't it
yeah and september's real real hot
i know why the urgency
well we live in los angeles uh which i
feel like speaks for itself um we we
want to get the heck out of dodge if i'm
going to be completely honest go now
what about in 30 days
well my husband uh
has not been approved to work remotely
yet and so that's part of what we're
waiting for also i'm a swim instructor
so we're hoping that i can crank out a
bunch of swim lessons make a ton of
money and then we can move after that
my hope is to be a stay-at-home mom if
that's possible
but we want to buy a house and so
i'm looking for some insight as to
whether or not you think
now with the economy is going to be the
right time we would have 10 percent to
put down uh which is not you're
debt-free
yes we are on baby step 3b if you're
buying a home financially and you're
debt-free and you put down a reasonable
down payment and your payment is no more
than a fourth of your income on a 15
year fixed that's okay
however
most people don't make really really
great decisions in their third trimester
and moving in your third trimester
as a father of three sounds like a
really
dangerous idea i might wait till january
yeah personally
up to you